et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stéphane troussel
37 président socialiste du conseil
départemental de la seine saint denis
membre du bureau national du parti
socialiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une tension en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour il met un bon jeu rien bonjour
monsieur bonjour et stéphane troussel
longues nuits longues discussions hier
au conseil national du parti socialiste
vous aussi merci d'être là malgré cette
mi connu courte l'accord a donc été
validé à 62% vous étiez favorable à cet
accord vous êtes sur la ligne de livres
pour vous êtes soulagé ce matin oui
soulagé surtout soulagé parce que ce
sont nos électeurs qui je crois
attendait cet engagement des socialistes
dans cette nouvelle alliance dans ce
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes sans exclusive quand il y à
90% des électeurs de gauche qui souhaite
le rassemblement est d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vu lors des élections
présidentielles s'étaient aussi cette
cette demande qui était fortement
exprimée et qui avait d'ailleurs
contribué à ce fort vote utile dès le
premier tour en forme en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon donc oui je suis
soulagé y compris parce que disons le
c'est une forme de clarification les
électeurs de gauche ne savait plus
vraiment où se situait le parti
socialiste compte tenu de ce qui s'est
passé c'est des cinq dernières années
compte tenu ce qui s'était passé au
moment de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 et donc ce vote il signifie aussi
très clairement que le parti socialiste
est dans un camp celui de la gauche
c'était c'était vraiment nécessaire de
rappeler de rappeler celle que le ps
était vraiment de gauche à l'évidence à
l'évidence compte tenu à la fois des
incertitudes des parcours y compris
individuelle d'un certain nombre
d'anciens responsables du parti
socialiste quant au soir de l'élection
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous n'avez aucun des
responsables du parti socialiste
d'aujourd'hui sur les plateaux de
télévision mais vous avez tous ceux
d'hier qui se promènent en expliquant
finalement qu'il fallait faire d'autres
choix qu'il fallait rejoindre les rives
de la macro ni je pense est visuellement
et évidemment à manuel valls par exemple
eh bien ça trouble nos électeurs ça fait
ça ça entretient doute sur notre
identité politique et ce vote d'hier
soir eh bien il dit clairement ou non
je sais ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
stéphane troussel et est ce que les gens
qui sont opposés à cet accord notamment
françois hollande jean-marc ayrault
bernard cazeneuve jacques tène parti
tout seul mais folle de stéphane le foll
est ce qu'ils doivent quitter le parti
pour que la clarification et jusqu'au
bout mais écoutez c'est un peu ce qu'a
dit au dj fort il a dit si je passe
qu'il a dit c'est le message était assez
transparent ou avec nous ou bien par t
c'est ce qu'il a dit effectivement si
vous pensez que seul le camp de la
gauche celui-là qui va effectivement moi
je n'ai jamais été sur la ligne de cette
théorie des gauches irréconciliables
parce que l'histoire de la gauche oui
c'est des différences oui c'est un
certain nombre de désaccords oui c'est
un certain nombre de points sur lesquels
nous avons en permanence besoin de
confrontation pour arriver à des
compromis sur les questions
internationales cpad c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui ça donne ça remonte allons
donc doigt sur l'élection européenne les
états eux de se poser la question c'est
à eux de se poser la question de savoir
où est leur camp où l heure quand est ce
que c'est le camp de la gauche que la
gauche c'est d'abord le rassemblement de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
besoin de l'action publique qui ont
besoin de dû justement de réponse aux
problèmes de la société d'aujourd'hui et
notamment aux problèmes qui sont posés
aux catégories populaires et à la
jeunesse la gauche s'est d'abord
répondre aux aspirations des catégories
populaires et de la jeunesse les
catégories populaires et la jeunesse de
ce pays aujourd'hui ils n'en peuvent
plus des le quinze de mots du mois ils
n'en peuvent plus des incertitudes face
à l'avenir ils n'en peuvent plus face
aux incertitudes quant à l'avenir de la
planète et bien c'est à cela d'abord
qu'on doit répondre et c'est ici ou là
et se sont pas tournés vers vous pour
allah président exactement
ils voulaient voter marine le pen ou
jean luc mélenchon et bien voir jeunes
et bien moi je ne me résoudrai jamais à
ce que les catégories populaires de ce
pays elles elles s'abstiennent elle se
résigne où elles votent à l'extrême
droite et donc le signal que nous
envoyons aussi hier soir avec ce vote
c'est de se dire que les catégories
populaires qui désespère qui désespère
soit en s'abstenant qui désespère soit
on va t'en en votant marine le pen est
bien que la gauche elle est de retour
elle est de retour parce qu'elle se
rassemble ses trousses elle le signale
que vous en voyez ce que c'est pas une
forme d'une scop les moines mais de
soumission à la france insoumise mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
de quel soumission parle-t-on je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il n'ya pas si
longtemps que ça jean luc mélenchon et
les insoumis et je considère que c'est
justement le résultat de ces discussions
depuis dix jours ils ne reconnaissaient
pas qu'il ne reconnaissait plus le
clivage gauche droite il était dans un
autre clivage celui entre les populistes
et les élites et bien le depuis dix
jours leur préoccupation c'est de
rassembler la gauche et c'est de
remettre y compris le parti socialiste
dans le camp de la gauche et bien moi
aussi je considère que c'est une
évolution de leur part que y compris ce
sur quoi nous sommes arrivés sur la
question européenne
là aussi c'est une évolution ils ne
voulaient entendre que le terme de
désobéissance et finalement nous
arrivons un texte qui mieux parle de de
rester dans la construction européenne
de rester dans l'union européenne de la
réorienter on n'entend plus parler de
deviner qui vivait de en vérité ainsi
qui dit qu'on va déroger à des règles
mais en même temps qu'on va travailler
ce qui est tout et son contraire en fait
on ne peut pas à la fois à dire je ne
vais pas respecter les traités puis dire
en même temps aux partenaires européens
on va travailler pour changer les
traités mécaniquement qu'on va
travailler pour réorienter la soirée
pour changer les traités sous les obus
l'union européenne s'est toujours des
compromis qui sont issues de rapports de
force politiques et vous connaissez mon
histoire je suis président du
département de la seine saint denis j'ai
succédé à claude bartolone qui est
devenu président de l'assemblée
nationale un an après l'élection de
françois hollande à la présidence de la
république qu'est ce que disait claude
bartolone le quatrième personnage de
l'état il faut assumer la confrontation
la confrontation avec l'allemagne sur
les lacs sur la chance sur les licences
et
les étés peu d'athlètes attendait accord
avec nous je vous parle de là les jeunes
que je vous parle je prends un exemple
sur la question européenne
il disait quoi il disait qu'il ne
fallait pas respecté la règle des 3% que
c'était un objectif absurde qu'est ce
qu'il n'avait pas entendu à l'époque
mais est-ce qu'il n'avait pas entendu ça
lui est acceptée dans une forme de
compromis par par l'union européenne et
d'ailleurs ça y est ça n'est les prix
des loyers et bien c'est bien l'exemple
mais parce qu'il fait mais le fruit
aussi d'une d'une négociation bien union
européenne
désobéissance de tension de tension de
confrontation justement pour faire
bouger l'union européenne eh bien c'est
exactement ce qui est proposé dans le
texte qui est commun sur la répartition
de l'espèce l'inscription à l'heure
actuelle à l'assemblée nationale vous
avez une trentaine de députés dans
l'accord vous avez 70 circonscriptions
les écolos ils ont zéro députés dans
l'accord il on sent circonscription est
ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu fait avoir
mais attendez qu'il y ait des déceptions
c'est bien normal et moi je pense
effectivement à tous ces responsables
militants élus socialistes qui se
préparait à cette élection mais dans
quel état nous sommes arrivés autour de
la table des négociations sur la base de
notre résultat aux élections
présidentielles
1,74 % à cette élection c'est ça la
réalité et c'est sur cette base là
malheureusement qui ne fait rien
s affaiblit avec un ps affaibli
évidemment évidemment ce que je propose
c'est que l'on vous me rées invitiez au
lendemain du deuxième tour de l'élection
législative et nous verrons quelle est
la situation politique et c'est
seulement à partir de cela et de la
composition des différents groupes de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale que nous
jugerons à la fois ci cet accord a
permis au parti socialiste et bien de
rester un acteur politique nationale
dans la future assemblée parce que c'est
ça qui compte oui nous avons fait ce
choix à la fois nous appuyant sur notre
implantation territoriale est d'ailleurs
demain la gauche à l'assemblée nationale
quelle que soit la configuration
opposition majorité elle devra s'appuyer
non seulement sur les groupes
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
mais aussi sur les sur les élus locaux
et les élus dans les communes dans les
départements et les régions eh bien ils
sont majoritairement socialistes
communistes et confirmez vous pensez
sauver combien de députés avec cet
accord et j'en sais rien mais à
l'évidence de toute façon c'est à minima
la reconstruction à la part dont la
reconduction d'un groupe aux alentours
de 30 35 40 j'espère et plus s'il y a
une dynamique qui s'enclenche parce que
c'est ça l'intérêt de cette nouvelle
union populaire écologiste et sociale
c'est la dynamique qu'elle enclenche
dans l'ensemble du pays et donc y
compris dans les circonscriptions dont
on voit bien qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
jouable comme on dit et permettent
justement la victoire est ce que est ce
que comme qu'est ce que vous répondez à
la président de la région occitanie
carole delga une simple aussi les propos
de la maire de paris anne hidalgo qui il
semble dire que l'accord s'est fait sans
laissant les élus locaux et que
finalement ce que vous critiquez à
propos des mails malgres on c'est à dire
c'est un peu sa défiance vis-à-vis
d'aidé des élus des élus locaux vous
reproduisez la même chose
écoutez encore une fois bien sûr qu'il y
à des déceptions bien sûr qu'il y avait
des militants ou des candidats qui
étaient en train de s'engager compte
tenu de ce qu'est leur engagement
politique mais chacun sait bien
notamment depuis qu'il y a à la fois le
quinquennat et l'inversion du calendrier
que
l'élection les élections législatives
qui suivent l'élection présidentielle
sont dans une dans le prolongement de
l'élection de l'élection présidentielle
et pour les principales forces
politiques qui ont
performé lors de l'élection
présidentielle et bien si ce sont eux
qui donnent le la de des résultats de
des élections législatives il suffit de
regarder ce qui s'est passé en 2010
cette iapp le lorsqu'un candidat lorsque
notre candidat dans une circonscription
faisait 6 7 8 % le candidat socialiste
qui portait le drapeau quelques semaines
après l'élection aux élections
législatives dans le meilleur des cas il
faisait quoi à 10,12 à l'évincer
empêchait la qualification au deuxième
tour dans ces attentions et olivier faur
l'a fait hier attention aux candidatures
or
hors union est-ce que clairement vous
vous dites aux gens qui seraient tentés
par cette aventure ils font le choix les
y font une erreur
moi je ne vous prononcer aujourd'hui un
qu aucun mot qui empêcherait les
socialistes de se retrouver et de se
rassembler je sais la force de nos élus
locaux jeu c'est la force de de nos élus
locaux dans les communes dans les
départements et régions en particulier
dans ce territoire qu'est l'occitanie et
et moi je sais que ce qui ce qui ce qui
nous unit est bien plus fort que tout le
reste en particulier bien sûr avec tous
ceux de la famille socialiste donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour ces
candidats
tron est retardé on verra bien dans les
jours qui viennent ce que les uns et les
autres seront je vous je vous invite là
aussi à regarder dedans vos décors
jusqu'au bout je vous invite à regarder
ce qui se passera d'ici le 20 mai on
verra bien les réalités de terrain on
verra bien comment les uns et les autres
iront au bout ou pas de ces candidatures
parce que quand il y à des dynamiques
politiques eh bien ça oblige chacun
chacune à se poser des questions
jusqu'au bout donc attendons le 20 mai
et on verra c'est la date limite de
dépôt des candidatures et on verra où
nous en serons assis là - carole delga
michaël delafosse et non ont déjà dit
qu'ils feraient campagne pour ces
candidats qui sont implantées dans leur
région est ce que ils ont encore leur
place au parti socialiste moi je crois
que tous ils ont leur place au parti
socialiste et je ne souhaite pas que le
parti socialiste c'est ce se divisent ou
c pure
en excluant qui que ce soit donc nous
verrons nous avons rappelé à la france
un souvenir parce que adrien 85 ans même
a eu de numéro deux de la france
insoumise a quand même eu plus ou moins
une expression pour dire que les
dissidents du parti socialiste devraient
être ex ex qu'elle chacune de ces des
familles politiques qui composent cette
cette nouvelle alliance aura à prendre
des décisions dans les semaines qui
viennent mais ce que je propose c'est
que on regarde ce qui se passe jusqu'au
20 mai et à partir du 20 mai qu à un
moment de la date limite du dépôt des
candidatures
et je pense que chacun saura en
conscience en responsabilités en
fonction des dynamiques politiques qui
s'installeront à partir de maintenant
obligé de se reposer quelques questions
mais vous pourriez peut-être sur le fait
que certains en effet refusé l'obstacle
mais qu'est ce que vous dites par
exemple à la à la députée 1 dont la
l'élection a été invalidée lamia el
harrach qui doit donner une conférence
de presse ce matin pour dire si elle
robrig quand même son mandat malgré le
fait que on lui impose la candidature de
danielle simonnet une proche de jean luc
mélenchon ou les dites quoi n'y allez
pas
je pense que vous avez avant moi invités
1 le sénateur de paris rémi féraud qui
connaît bien la situation parisienne et
qui a dû vous dire qu'elle était à la
fois au niveau ces vautours des loups
qui m'a inquiété notre niveau de
déception et
notre espérance notre espoir qu'une
solution puisse être trouvée je ne sais
pas quelle est qu'elle puisse être cette
semaine qu'elle peut-être cette solution
vis-à-vis de cette députée qui a fait un
travail formidable amiens incarne cette
nouvelle génération est donc moi aussi
je ne suis pas satisfait de cette
situation et donc j'espère qu'une
solution pourrait trouver quel peut-être
ses solutions jeunes en selle
chacun sait que y compris dans sept
sites dans cette circonscription en
dépit du travail formidable qui a pu
faire lamia et bien nous avons fait un
score excessivement faibles à l'élection
à l'élection présidentielle c'est ça nos
difficultés chacun dans
les urnes oui mais vous savez bien vous
lassez d'accord mais vous savez bien que
les situations sont différentes vous
savez bien que le niveau de
participation n'est pas le même donc on
ne peut pas tout comparer et donc encore
une fois attendait les heures les jours
les semaines qui viennent
vous comprenez finalement que la france
insoumise défendre la candidature de
danielle simonnet
vous encore une fois vous voyez bien les
difficultés dans lequel ce type d'accord
nous met partout sur le terrain oui il y
à des déceptions quand il ya soixante
dix circonscriptions dans lesquelles
nous allons porter nos couleurs et les
couleurs de cette alliance et bien oui
c'est des difficultés oui c'est des
déceptions y compris personnels dans un
certain nombre de situations et donc
mais je crois encore une fois que dans
cette situation est alors 90 % des
électeurs de gauche chouette le
rassemblement et bien c'est ça qu'on
nous avons dit r d'abord et apporter des
couleuvres avalées
moi je ne me gêne je ne reprends pas
d'autre terme parce qu'encore une fois
ce qui compte c'est le rassemblement de
la gauche et les écologistes et sacs
nous demandent nos électeurs depuis des
mois des années eh bien ces sacs
signifie ce vote d'hier soir est ce que
si vous perdez les législatives cet
accord est encore valable est ce que ça
peut être un accord d'opposition ou vous
ferez l'inventaire après la défaite et
chacun repartira de son côté d'abord
aucune des formes formation politique
qui s'est rassemblée dans le cas de cet
accord n'a décidé de disparaître dans un
parti unique la gauche c'est d'abord sa
pluralité c'est d'abord sa diversité
c'est des histoires des parcours des
références différentes mais avec cet
accord ce que nous disons c'est qu'il ya
plus de convergences que de différences
plus de combats communs que nous allons
mener ensemble moi j'espère que le plus
longtemps possible
au lendemain de ces élections
législatives bien évidemment en cas de
victoire dans un gouvernement de gauche
ou demain dans une opposition renforcée
pour s'opposer pied à pied à tous tous
les reculs tous les projets libéraux de
d'emmanuel macro et de sa nouvelle
majorité si si c'était le cas eh bien
nous permettra d'être de continuer
d'être ensemble pour réorienter la
construction européenne pour défendre
justement la retraite pour ceux qui ont
été usés par des métiers pénibles et qui
ont commencé à travailler jeunes nous
opposer à la retraite à 65 ans empêché
le travail et forcé pour les
allocataires du rsa bien c'est tout ça
que nous allons faire ensemble et y
compris pour faire prévaloir d'autres
choix d'autres projets et une autre
perspective encore une fois pour celles
et ceux qui n'en peuvent plus et vie
dure dès le 15 du mois pour redonner de
l'espoir à la jeunesse de ce pays pour
redonner espoir aux catégories
populaires qui qui se sentent abandonnés
par la désindustrialisation du pays par
la désertification médicale par la
disparition des services publics dans
les quartiers populaires comme dans un
certain nombre de territoires ruraux
c'est tout ça que nous allons faire
ensemble mais chacun bien sûr restera
dans son identité dans son organisation
politique et puis la recomposition
politique la reconstruction politique y
compris de chacune de nos formations
politiques elle ne fait que commencer on
va y venir mais juste de ce que vous ne
dites matin on sait que vous n'êtes plus
en position de force aujourd'hui pour
imposer quoi que ce soit finalement
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui est en
position de force est ce qu'il a réussi
actuel parti socialiste d'abord le parti
le g10 est encore là et il l'aura 70
candidats dans dans cette élection
législative et moi je compte bien que
nombre d'entre eux plus de la moitié
d'entre eux et unième peut-être au-delà
vont être élu le 19 juin prochain et
puis le parti socialiste c'est des élus
locaux c'est un tiers des départements
c'est des grandes villes c'est
5,5 région et donc vous voyez bien que
c'est une force politique qui compte
mais par contre bien évidemment si nous
voulons à nouveau être au coeur de la
gauche eh bien il va falloir tout
repensé pour salle au plafond et quand
vous reconstruire jean luc mélenchon n'a
peut-être pas que tu es le ps mais ce
qu'il en est pas devenu le patron de
fait
non l'ancien frondeurs qui est qu'il
cherchait justement à prendre le parti
finalement c'est une formidable revanche
oui certainement certainement et puis
vous savez c'est aussi le résultat de
ces institutions de la vème république
quand quand il y a quelqu'un qui a été
trois fois candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
alors que le parti socialiste en ce qui
me concerne n'a pas été en situation par
exemple en 2012 de pouvoir présenter le
président de la république issu de ses
rangs qui venait de deux de finir un
quinquennat c'est une de ces peu je
crois principale difficulté dans des
comptes nous n'avons pas été capables de
porter avec celui qui a dirigé l'action
des socialistes entre 2012 et 2017 de
faire valoir notre bilan par celui là
c'est de mon point de vue la principale
des difficultés ça veut dire qu'en fait
c'est françois hollande le premier
responsable de l'affaiblissement du
parti socialiste aujourd'hui en tout cas
à l'évidence moi je considère que
un quinquennat marqué par par exemple
cice et le pacte de responsabilité sans
aucune contrepartie en terme d'emploi en
termes de salaires en termes de
conditions de travail c'est une
difficulté le débat se nauséabonds sur
la déchéance de dix filles de la
nationalité c'est une de nos difficultés
la loi travail c'est une de nos
difficultés donc oui je considère qu' il
est à dire tant le ps n'est plus de
gauche je considère en tout cas c'est ce
que nous ont dit nos électeurs c'est ce
que nous ont dit nos lecteurs nous ne
nous reconnaissons pas quand vous
oubliez un certain nombre de vos valeurs
et donc c'est une forme aussi de claix
clarification par rapport à cette
dernière expérience gouvernementale à
nos de ce que vous nous dites c'est que
c'est le dernier clou sur le cercueil du
hollandisme une employée par en tout cas
moi je ne m'en lasse pas ces termes là
parce qu'encore une fois je sais qu'elle
a été l'engagement le dévouement de des
responsables politiques des responsables
socialistes de ce quinquennat je sais
qu'elle est et le dévouement
l'engagement des députés socialistes qui
jusqu'au bout y compris hong et essayer
de faire bouger les choses c'est le cas
d'ailleurs de d'olivier fort lui même à
plusieurs reprises dans ce quinquennat
il a tenté de trouver des compromis il a
tenté de faire évoluer l'action
gouvernementale il a tenté de parvenir
un autre équilibre de l'action politique
qui est est ce que ça a été ça a été
refusé y compris par les responsables de
la halle de la mairie telle erreur
d'olivier fort ça n'a pas été de ne pas
avoir fait l'inventaire du quinquennat
hollande de ne pas avoir tourné
clairement ce n'est pas violent 10 pour
le parti socialiste je crois que vous
avez tort parce qu'en l'occurrence cet
inventaire il a été fait vous l'avez
peut-être pas entendu mais il a été fait
ça lui était reproché d'ailleurs par un
certain nombre de ceux qui s'expriment
aujourd'hui mais je crois que justement
c'est peut-être une certaine manière ce
que
ce qui est a été là maintenant entendus
en termes de clarification politique et
ce qui était attendu par nos électeurs
de gauche mais du coup de pression parce
à l'aps a pas été très clair votre
réponse s'est faite roussel est ce
qu'aujourd'hui françois hollande doit
quitter le parti socialiste pour que la
clarification et jusqu'au bout est ce
qu'il n'a plus sa place dans le parti
oui mais vous ne m'entendrez jamais dire
ça parce que je considère moi ce qui a
fait la force du parti socialiste ce qui
lui a permis de jouer un rôle central au
coeur de la gauche pendant toutes ces
années où il a été encore une fois la
force motrice du rassemblement de la
gauche c'est quand il était capable de
rassembler le gérard filoche à gérard
collomb à partir du moment où le parti
socialiste a été dans une situation où
chacune de ses composantes de ce qui lui
a permis encore une fois d'être au coeur
de la gauche c'en était écarté et bien
il n'a plus été en capacité joué sept
rôles ce rôle moteur au sein de la
gauche il n'empêche qu'avec cet accord
derrière la force motrice de jean luc
mélenchon qui est quand même l'or
représente plutôt de la gauche radicale
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur que une
partie des électeurs de gauche qui ont
voté anne hidalgo mais au delà même qui
refuse la la la prédominance de jean luc
mélenchon se tourner vers emmanuel
macron d'abord il y en a malheureusement
pas beaucoup qui ont voté pour nous au
premier tour il y en a plus beaucoup qui
ont voté pour beaucoup d'autres qui ont
voté de façon à utiliser la vie de jean
luc mélenchon mais qu'ils ne réclament
pas forcément qu'il souhait devienne
premier ministre oui mais d'ailleurs
cette question là elle elle est devant
nous moi je ne considère pas que pour
gouverner ce pays il faudra s'aligner
sur les positions les plus radicales
bien évidemment qu'il faudra trouver
donc vous voulez quand même jean luc
mélenchon comme produit de ligne je je
laissez moi finir je considère ma
réponse je ne considère pas que pour
gouverner ce pays il faudra s'aligner
sur les positions les plus radicales je
pense qu'il faut un nouveau compromis
politique c'est ce que c'est ce que nous
faisons dans le cadre de cette de ceux
de cette alliance et oui ça serait bien
ça sera bien normal si la gauche est
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale
compte tenu que le groupe de la france
insoumis sera le premier groupe
politique dans cette nouvelle alliance
que son leader ça à chaque fois été
comme ça c'était le cas en 97 quand
lionel jospin est devenu premier
ministre que le premier groupe politique
de cette nouvelle alliance il dirige le
gouvernement il de 60 des programmes
mais il n'y aura pas de majorité de la
france insoumise seul demain à
l'assemblée nationale si la gauche est
majoritaire donc bien évidemment qu'il
faudra trouver des compromis comme
lionel jospin trouver des compromis avec
les communistes et avec les écologistes
et jean luc vernay jean luc mélenchon à
matignon est ce que ça vous inquiète
mais c'est à lui de savoir quelle sera
la feuille de route justement mais
je ne m'inquiète pas alors que justement
sa feuille de route ça sera de trouver
un nouveau coq il faut me champ
politique donc il faut qu'ils changent
mais ce n'est pas là mais qu'à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure actuelle tels que
sans condition et je remarque ça
pourrait vous encore une fois je reviens
à ce que je vous disais au début de
notre entretien ce que je remarque c'est
jean luc mélenchon et les insoumis ont
déjà changé on déjà changé puisque par
exemple clivage okalys que ce serait
faire désormais c'est bien le clivage
gauche droite que y compris sur l'union
européenne le texte qu'il a signé avec
le parti socialiste n'est pas l'occident
sur le nucléaire
lisez le texte que nous avons signés y
compris sur le cren et vous verrez bien
que juste
derrière la souveraineté sur lui car
c'est bien la souveraineté et la liberté
de l'ukraine et du peuple crise couve
régnant cet ennemi des fondu en
larmes hier a lancé sa candidature dans
le nord candidature aux législatives
évidemment il en appelle aux électeurs
de gauche déçus par les trahisons du
parti socialiste ça me fait sourire ces
questions là ses propos de toute cette
droite qui pendant des années nous a
stigmatisés méprisés qui a oublié
qu'entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle
il voulait la mobilisation des électeurs
de gauche pour justement faire réélire
emmanuel macron et qui aujourd'hui par
se rassemble et qui parce que la gauche
se rassemble finalement se souvient de
nos gloires passées de nos succès donc
tout ça me fait sourire ce cette
soudaine défense de ce que serait à
leurs yeux l'identité du parti
socialiste quand gérald hama darmanin
explique que marine le pen est trop
molle très franchement tout ça va bien
faire rire pleurer peut-être plus tôt
les électeurs de gauche merci stéphane
mercier ainsi beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité julien la une de la voix du nord
le malaise des infirmières c'est à la
une de votre journal merci beaucoup
merci d'être venus nombreux
[Musique]